what are you doing what am i do my last
time you did it you turned everything
blue and red I was washing the the
American flag my my flag no one washes
the flag washes the flag all right
laundry's Sheriff
you know what it is I love about being
spider-man
you okay just fine yeah I know costume
gives it away huh max you don't want
your badge
Oscorp knows I ain't nobody hey like
that you're my eyes and ears out
must be pretty cool to have the hope
where I'll see you like that
amazing spider-man
I wish I was like him
I like to think the spider-man gives
people hope
yo sparkles you don't remember me
of course I remember you you're my eysan
is oh what's your name again
why do I know it I know it don't tell me
it's fun it's a Matt yes
Peter Parker very odd poor you're gonna
want to see this Oscar had you under
surveillance
why is not the question of the day we
have plans for you
Parker in the future
we literally can change the world
thing is what I thought it was
this is bigger than you Peter
wanted to be
a big prize
what happened to your face it's filthy I
was cleaning the chimney we have no
chimney hey youtubers is Charlie and
Sony just posted the second half of the
Amazing Spiderman trailer during the
Superbowl it highlights some more of the
Clone Saga storyline as well as you know
the genetic testing that Norman Osborn
has been doing careful for spoilers if
you don't want to know anything about
the Clone Saga because it kind of
informs where Sony is taking the
franchise especially with the spin-off
movie the sinister six movie that
they're developing so Clone Saga
explained in a couple seconds Norman
Osborn takes genetic material from Peter
Parker to make other supers those should
kind of see the Hall of Heroes you know
with all those different suits we even
saw doctor octopus's arms in that case
but you see the vulture you see a bunch
of other supervillains that's gonna be
part of the sinister six movie that
they're spinning off the interesting
thing about the Clone Saga Norman Osborn
was behind it all
but Doctor Octopus was the one that was
doing all the testing Dane DeHaan also
had a lot of new scenes in the trailer -
I'm actually looking forward to his
version of Harry Osborn I mean James
Franco is good but I don't think he can
go dark the way that Dane DeHaan can I
don't know if it'll be in the movie but
also during that Clone Saga Norman
Osborn has a psychiatrist brainwash
Harry so that he forgets all about the
Green Goblin we did get a really good
look at his suit though which actually
looks pretty badass
way better than the James Franco version
Mary Jane was also a big part of this
story but they cut her out of the movie
just to keep it from turning into
spider-man 3 she ends up getting dosed
and turned into this big monster so I
think they just wanted to make it as
simple as possible so I think that was
actually a good decision even though
shilling willy is an amazing actress the
thing that I'm most excited to see is
the Jamie Foxx origin story just like
Captain America Winter Soldier is gonna
be an origin story for the villain this
is gonna be an origin story for him I
feel like all sequels are like that in
the first movie of any franchise you
know you have a hero origin story so the
sequel naturally has to have a villain
origin story that kind of mirrors that
Felicity Jones is also a big part of the
movie and it's rumored that she's
playing black cat we didn't see her in
the trailer we didn't see any black cat
I think they're kind of trying to keep
that under wraps so we'll see about that
maybe in a future trailer let me know
what your favorite moment from the
trailer was though and are you super
pumped to see a sinister six movie I
know this movie hasn't even come out yet
if you didn't see already I also posted
the Captain America Winter Soldier
second trailer you can click here to
watch that it's gonna be an origin story
for the Winter Soldier character and you
can click here to watch my other Super
Bowl trailers I'm at least doing
transformers 4 so I'll try to upload
that later tonight thanks so much for
watching
see you guys tomorrow high fives